tout le monde est déjà à l'intérieur papa
une explosion a secoué la ville aujourd'hui
20 000 livres pour les noms des
bombardiers ce n'est pas comme ça que nous faisons les choses ici
c'est cinq jours de suite maintenant que veut-
il sa
fille a été tuée dans l'attentat à la bombe m.
Hennessy s'il vous plaît découvrez les noms
des bombardiers Je travaille pour le gouvernement
pas des terroristes
vous le ferez pour travailler pour eux Je ne sais pas
comment sont les bombardiers ne
vous croyez pas c'est lui vous me diriez les noms
des bombardiers  l'escalier mardi, il s'est
entraîné à peine sur les mots
peut-être que les forces spéciales veulent juste que vous
sachiez qu'il peut vous comprendre ce qui se passe
pense que je sais qui était la fille de Lord est-ce
que quelqu'un dit une prière mais toujours la moitié de
la ville regarde à partir de
là tu dois vivre rencontrer  les filles oh l'homme qui
tourne en rond autour de beaucoup d'entre nous
devant nous à chaque étape du chemin
ouvre-le
[Musique]
oui je te fais toi